c'est un véritable sport que se livrent
chaque soir les banlieusards de tokyo et
quel sport il s'agit pour plus de 3
millions de travailleurs de trouver une
place dans l'un des wagons du métro pour
nom d'un effet niveau viable
et ceux qui parviennent à monter ne
peuvent pas se vanter de le faire sans
dommage
si bien que le métro de tokyo est en
mesure d'ouvrir un marché de chaussures
et de boutons d'occasions
cet état de choses n'a pas été sans
attirer l'attention des autorités
compétentes qui ont organisé une série
de conférences destiné à éduquer le
public
d'autre part pour mettre un peu d'ordre
dans ce désordre
on a établi une série de barrages propre
à fractionner le flux des usagers
enfin on a créé une brigade spéciale
qu'on pourrait appeler brigade de
compression
les employés qui en font partie sont
préposés aux différentes portières ou
leur mission est de faire entrer à
l'intérieur tous qui débat
[Musique]
solution logique sans doute énergique
sans conteste mais qui n'a qu'un
lointain rapport avec l'idée que l'on
peut se faire des commodités du progrès
[Musique]